the ability to express emotion is the
hallmark of a great actor may the
emotions you will be seeing in a moment
from one of the five nominated best
actors won't be acting trust me I
remember and you probably all remember
how wimpy I was too so the nominees are
Russell Crowe in the insider
Richard Farnsworth
Jon Hamm
Kevin Spacey
zel Washington
and the Oscar goes to Kevin Spacey
this is Kevin Spacey's second
or he won an Oscar
the supporting role in the usual
suspects
this is the highlight of my day
I hope that is not all downhill from
here I first have to say that I would
like to dedicate this to the man who
inspired my performance a man who has
been my friend and my mentor and since
my father died a little bit like my
father whose performance in the
apartment stands is one of the finest
we've ever had Jack Lemmon wherever you
are thank you thank you thank you
to my friends for pointing out my worst
qualities I know you do it because you
love me
and that's why I love playing Leicester
because we got to see all of his worst
qualities and we still grew to love him
and this movie to me is all about how
any single act from any single person
put out a context is damnable but the
joy of this movie is that it is real
beauty and we found real beauty in this
extraordinary script by Sam Mendes by
Alan Ball it feels like he wrote it
though doesn't it I have I'm very proud
to be an actor and I have tried very
hard to protect my work and I am I'm
stunned and I'm a bit speechless and
Diane thank you for teaching me about
caring about the right things and I love
you and mother I don't care what they
say about bringing you to award shows I
will always bring you to award shows
because I'm proud of you and I love you
and thank you thank you thank you
you